[Music]
first things first let's make sure that
you're in the right room
show of hands who cares about cloud
costs controlling your cloud costs not
overspending by most of you so you found
the right room for those of you who did
not raise your hands and therefore cost
as no objects throw as much money as you
can make sure you find me after this
session and I'll introduce you to some
sales reps who would love to meet you
guys
all jokes aside my name is Nick Korolev
I'm a customer engineer with Google
cloud in a few minutes I'm gonna be
joined with a lot Amit who is the
director of product development at
perimeter X and we have a really
exciting to talk to you today all right
so what we'll be going through is
essentially the why and more importantly
the how of cloud management cloud cost
management we'll do a deep dive into how
to tie your KPIs or business KPIs to
those costs things like how much does it
cost to bring on a new customer how much
does it cost to sell a widget or to get
an extra pair of eyeballs looking at
your ad or to click on a link etc we'll
go through some real-world problems some
real scenarios and how to accomplish
that and we'll wrap it up with some best
practices and QA speaking of QA one of
the exciting things that we have for
this next session is something called
dory so everyone when we go to the Q&A
segment can ask questions online this is
open right now so essentially if you
just open up your next app go to the
session the CSD 302 submit Dory
questions through the plus sign and then
you can thumbs-up thumbs-down Dory
questions at the end of the session
we'll have about 10 minutes or so for
Q&A and we'll be alternating between the
Dory as well as the in-person mics so
definitely use that if it's convenient
okay so why analyze your cloud costs I
think the first reason is going to be
pretty self-explanatory
costs are directly tied to revenue of
your business it's a it's a bit of a
delicate equation here and the most
important part is costs do sometimes go
up but if costs go up you also have to
make sure that income is going up on par
or preferably at a fast
to pace than costs this is going to be
critical to your overall business but
it's also crucial for each business unit
and each team that contributes to these
costs so providing these business
metrics not only to CFO Z iOS etc but
also to those teams who are engineering
and building these solutions is pretty
powerful
second is usage is directly tied to
costs in the cloud world with on-prem
environments truthfully it was a little
bit easier to manage costs because you
bought one server and that server
essentially cost the same roughly the
same whether you are at 0% utilization
or 100% utilization and so when you
wanted your app to scale you're really
bound by that single server or X number
of servers and if you had wished it can
multiply into multiple servers it just
didn't have that capability with cloud
things operate differently differently
in a good way by things like auto
scaling by being able to click and
deploy new server instances you can
essentially grow your application from
one server to ten to a hundred to a
thousand in seconds and minutes but
there's a slight caveat there is that
usage is tied to cost and that as you
use more resources your costs increase
so much more important in this
environment to actually keep an eye on
how much your resources are costing you
and being able to kind of turn that dial
and adjust as you need the amount of
resources that you have and the amount
of costs that are contributing to your
business third thing is being in control
so by monitoring your costs you are the
point of control for your business you
can determine how much you're spending
on on GCE for instance and how that's
contributing to your business you can
keep track of what one business unit is
contributing to a business versus
another business unit one team versus
another team one individual versus
another individual etc potentially who's
running all those select stars in your
business and a fourth thing is being
intelligent so the saying goes that data
is the new the new oil the new gold etc
and that's very true the more data you
gather the more that you can actually do
with that data
so by actually collecting that data
by gathering it you can do more advanced
things like building dashboards that
compare your cost to your KPIs which
we'll be going through in the during the
session but you can also do more
advanced things like building ml models
to predict what your costs might be in
the future or building mo models to
potentially predict where you need to
focus your efforts on product XYZ or
widget ABC etc and most importantly is
you will inevitably inevitably save
money so by actually monitoring your
costs you will be able to keep track of
your costs and being able to tweak those
spending habits over time so I don't
know if you've done this yourself but a
couple years back I started more
thoroughly analyzing my personal
finances and was totally shocked to find
out how much the occasional $5 a cup of
coffee or the occasional dinner out with
friends etc actually ended up costing me
at the end of the month and so by
keeping an eye on that tracking that and
actually tailoring my spending habits I
ended up saving roughly about 10% per
month and once again my personal fan
finances so by actually just keeping an
eye and monitoring your spend costs you
will never bleep end up saving money so
let's take an example let's say that I
just open up a new exciting bike shared
company called G bike & Co as you can
see I'm renting out these amazing Google
bikes across the streets of San
Francisco business is booming ridership
is gone has gone up I have more people
getting becoming members etc but what I
really want to do is start identifying
how much my business is costing me and
actually converts something like the
number of bikes that are being driven or
ridden across the street to an
intelligent dashboard to show I my bike
trips are increasing while my costs are
decreasing stuff like that actually
providing more data to these numbers or
these assumptions and that's what we're
going to do during this session so first
I want to talk about kind of the cost
management 101 or what you can do right
out of the gate immediately through the
Google Cloud console first being built
in reports
so the
has some fantastic built-in reports that
allow you to actually tailor and drill
down into specific projects into
specific environments to see what those
costs are and maybe identify potential
red flags identified trends over time
etc and by the way all of these will
kind of go through some quick demos in a
couple minutes
second being resource hierarchy so
rather than bundling everything all your
DCP resources into one quote-unquote
bucket or one project being able to
intelligent intelligently separate one
project for another maybe have one
business that's to business unit that's
doing one thing versus another business
unit applying tags using organizations
projects folders etc for an example my
bike business like I said has been
booming but I'm interested in growing up
a separate business unit I'm gonna be
expanding into electric scooters for
everyone in San Francisco there's one
thing that we need more of and that is
electric scooters so I'm gonna be
building this out and I would
essentially put that under a separate
project so that I can more accurately
compare business units between those two
projects third being budgets and alerts
and so in the cloud console you can set
specific budgets and alert on those
budgets in a very granular level so if a
project goes over a certain threshold or
a billing account goes over through
certain threshold you don't have to be
left in the dark and find out with that
angry call at the months end to find out
why your project cost so much money you
can get that alert way before and start
to dial down those knobs and actually
control your costs by the way these
aren't the only things for the cost
management 101
besides these kind of out of the box you
have a billing API to do some more
advanced things you can set quotas for
your resources we have a ml capability
for actually recommending the specific
machine types in GCE stuff like that so
I definitely recommend kind of
identifying all the different areas that
you could go into this but what we're
really interested in this session is
kind of more
the advance stuff beyond the 101 and so
what I'm gonna be doing is more pulling
out a billing export from my cloud
console importing that into bigquery and
then doing some analytics across it to
identify potentially what my spend is
trends over time etc and bigquery being
Google's fully managed data warehouse
allows me to do things like break down
data silos do some complex join some
some creative sequel etc so I can
actually bring in some of my business
data some of my KPIs
pull that into the the same project or
even a different projects within
bigquery join across that and then kind
of output some interesting reports
through something like data studio or
really pick your bi provider of choice
and provide these dashboards to
management to leadership or even to
teams and engineers to kind of get a
better grasp of their spend so I'm gonna
just real quick go through some of the
one-on-one stuff so on my screen you can
see I have the the billing reports up
I'm looking at a range from the 25th to
the 9th by the way all these are just
kind of dummy numbers and stuff there's
an actual project but the numbers that
I'm gonna be going through through this
demo are pre fictitious fictitious so
over here I in the projects I can
actually expand this to include multiple
projects so you can see this blue line
being my production project the next
demo my orange line being the the test
dev I can also instead of goofing up my
project I can group it by product so you
can see that the majority of my cost is
going to spanner and then I have some
GCE I can further break it down by SKU
so I can find out exactly what my spends
are over time and I can even do some
advanced drill down to kind of get a
clearer picture of what the spend looks
like and in the previous image you can
actually see the trend line over time
granted this might not be the most
accurate kind of depends on how much
data has that's feeding into it to make
these projections and because this
project was started relatively recently
not the most accurate thing in the world
besides that I have budgets and alerts
so in here you see that I have two two
separate alerts that are set one for a
1,000 dollar next demo so at a specific
project level anything that exceeds a
50% 90 percent and a 100 percent
threshold send me alerts on I also have
one for the billing account so all the
different projects within that billing
account for five thousand limit to
create a budget I can simply go to just
dev I'm gonna pick my test up project
I'm going to set it to be one hundred
dollars maybe fifty dollars a little bit
too low to receive alerts on so I'll
change it to 80 and I'll click Save and
there you go now all of a sudden I have
a new budget that's been created and
that's gonna alert me if my test dev
team decides to go crazy and start
spending up a whole bunch of
environments next is the billing export
so go here there's two different ways to
export your billing data first is
through bigquery this would be my
preferred option it means that you can
do more with that data that's been
exported you can also export your data
as a CSV to export the data in bigquery
it is an automatic everyday sync between
your budget data and bigquery so what I
do is simply hit the set of settings
pick the project that I want to export
my billing data into the bigquery data
set that I want to export San Francisco
by company I'll collect save and there
we go now it's enabled and every day
it's going to start syncing my billing
data into bigquery so I can do more
advanced stuff with that so let's go to
bigquery and see what that looks like
it's roughly takes a handful of hours to
get that bill at the first billing
export into bigquery so what I've done
is I actually have a billing export
already in bigquery itself and if you
look at this schema you can see that
it's capturing some pretty decent
information so I have billing account
IDs you can see what service or SKU I'm
spending my money on projects labels the
specific location whether you're running
or GC instance in Asia or the u.s. total
costs usage credits all that kind of
stuff so some
really good data the challenges that I
want to make this more insightful and
actually compare it to my business KPIs
and so for that for my business data set
or business table I have this SF bike
trips table in my data set so by the way
this SF bike trips table is just
essentially a copy of the public data
set for the San Francisco bike and so by
all means feel free to kind of explore
this yourself and have at it
for this data essentially what I'm
capturing is information on every single
trip that my customers are taking so I
have the total duration of the trips
when the trip started and stops and
where I have information on like whether
that customer was a subscriber I like a
monthly paid membership or just someone
who walked off the street and and and
took a ride on my bicycle and so what
I'll do essentially is join these two
tables with a simple sequel query I
think everyone can still see that and so
essentially what I'll do is a join
between these two tables so I have this
SF bike trips table first off and what
I'm pulling out of this table are the
relevant information for me so I have
the number of trips where I'm counting
the total number of trips per day total
duration the the date itself I'm
counseling whether the customer was a
subscriber or just an off the street
customer and then I'm joining that to my
billing export and from my billing
export all I'm doing is pulling out the
particular day and the total cost per
day so you can see that this is
relatively simple but you can take this
to the next level of potentially which
areas are the most profitable profitable
for me
with this bike data that might tell me
maybe I should start placing more bikes
in a particular area or remove bikes
from other areas it might break into
things like maintenance and I could
joins across multiple tables and
identify okay I have a team of five
people who do maintenance on these bikes
where do I need to send them to be a
little bit more strategic with this and
so I'll go ahead and click run query and
you can see
once it finishes you can see that the
query has broken out the total number of
trips I'll just hide this total number
of trips and compared it to the cost so
on average I have somewhere between
2,000 and 4,000 trips per day my
subscriber numbers seem to be pretty
healthy my total cost per day once again
totally fictitious is somewhere between
turning twenty and thirty dollars per
day so it looks pretty good however the
challenge is that to my just normal
human eyes I can't really spot trends in
this data so what I would do is actually
open this up in data studio so there's
this fantastic Explorer data studio
button that's going to open up a net new
data studio project but let me just show
you the one that I've already created
this took about five minutes so it's
incredibly easy and what I have is a
couple different data points so first
let's look at this cost versus KPI
dashboard up here and the blue line you
can see are the total number of trips
and so there seems to be like a pretty
common trend here where maybe bikes get
ridden more during the work days and
then less or their work weekends people
writing their own bike stuff like that
hanging out with their their kids etc on
the weekends make sense and you can see
that the red bars are my total cost per
day now what I didn't tell you earlier
is that I've actually started a new
initiative to find out if I can adopt
more bike riders with let's just call it
a mobile app and so I started spending
more money on this mobile application
some around mid-february and you can see
that my costs have increase however the
blue line the total number of trips
haven't really increased in fact there's
some interesting dips I mean potentially
maybe it was rain or something like that
but right out the gate you can kind of
see that maybe this business initiative
isn't really as successful as the first
planned it's a B and so I can look at
these numbers down here below which kind
of summarized the total numbers across
the month and this actually proves my
point is that GCP costs per month have
risen by 55% kind of a warning sign
unless the bike trips have also
increased but they're actually down by
6.2 percent so a little concerning the
subscribers are also down and mine on
subscribers have only increased by one
percent so
right off the bat I can take this data
to my business to CFO or CTO etc and
kind of show them that maybe this trend
or this business initiative really isn't
panning out as much as possible so this
is more of kind of theoretical exercise
more of like the book smarts I'd like to
invite a lot of it on stage to talk to
more of the street smarts of actually
putting this into practice and all the
the business value you are able to
contribute back to Perimeter x thank you
very much thanks for that great intro
Nick like you said my name is allowed
meet the director of platform
development over crimini Rex where my
team is primarily in charge of scaling
our products and one of the things that
that entails is cost management just for
the context what we actually do is
something called Bob mitigation that is
we in just a boatload of traffic we
analyze it and we use it to block also
some malicious traffic stuff like
account abuse account takeover credit
card theft all sorts of nasty little
things and the problem is that a boat
worth of traffic costs are both on the
money
so naturally we try and give it the
attention it deserves now I know you
were promised a demo but instead what
I'm gonna do is tell you a story
switch the demo it's really a demo now
like every good story we have characters
in and our specific story starts with
our CFO was actually quite angry with us
at the time and rightfully so I mean all
he wanted to know was what our cloud
bills are gonna be like at the end of
the month and though that may sound like
a trivial question this was like two
years ago and two years ago what we
mostly had was all flat file export that
look kind of like this with very very
little dimensions that we could kind of
figure out what we were doing and though
as Nick showed you like a second ago
these days you already have these
nifty little projections that you can
understand what's going on at the time
they didn't exist for us the real
turning point was when we started using
do it and their tool called we optimized
to kind of start figuring out a little
bit better where we're gonna be at this
is specifically we optimized with some
projections that you can see here at
that point our CFO was quite happy but
as we grew and as we matured people
started asking some really weird
questions I mean up till then people
asked how much is stuff gonna cost and
at that point in time people started
asking how much is my stuff gonna cost
that this was like a this totally blew
our mind but so as we went into the
building export that and it showed you a
second ago
what you can see at the the default that
you're getting is mostly semantics based
on what Google is selling you I'm not
saying that as a negative thing because
that's actually what you're paying for
but if you can see here then what you're
mostly seeing is stuff like custom
instance the other containers this
active storage that and making the leap
from that to whatever it is that you're
building is somewhere between hard and
impossible now thankfully enough at that
point that this was like a year and a
half ago the building exports started
getting the user-defined labels pushed
into them and surprisingly enough they
were all is there we were using them
mostly for operational stuff to kind of
break down what we were using within
production and not surprisingly enough
we wanted to use the same breakdown to
kind of figure out where our costs were
going
to kind of simplify our lives a little
bit we chose to expose this additional
data using a view mostly because we
wanted to take away the complexity and
you'll see the complexity a little
further down the line of how to figure
out which specific dimensions are really
interesting in which or not now
specifically within this view you're
gonna want to notice two things the
first of which is that we're exporting a
column called partition time this
basically allows the bigquery query or
data studio queering bigquery to prune
the partitions and make your queries a
little bit cheaper for us the billing
data set is already around 2 terabytes
so it adds up and it makes sense and the
second thing you're gonna want to notice
is that we're trying to take away the
complexity of unnecessary to fields if
you're gonna be using this I highly
recommend you read up on a nested fields
because you can make really really bad
mistakes with them so what we have here
specifically is a summary of the amount
of credits and the specific label that
we want to use and if we go back to our
data studio reports then we can see that
once we break down our cost based on
this new building component that we've
added then the semantics you change
completely from what Google is selling
to what we are actually building here we
can see how much this specific front-end
component is costing us how much this
specific elasticsearch cluster is
costing us and this isn't just like the
cores or the lamp or any specific piece
it's everything the other nifty little
thing that you get when you add this is
that you can now not only see the
overall spend or just by SKU or by
component once you break down a specific
component by the SKUs then you can
figure out where to focus your
development efforts on optimization
which is what this whole talk is about
so if you take for example that online
component and we can see that it is
mostly a CPU intensive resource you can
see this is custom instance core in
America
the Virginia family correctly and so on
and so forth and to contrast that we
have this little thing which is mostly a
network intensive resource now another
thing to notice is that while you would
have probably gotten this from
operational dashboards you would have
not gotten the fact that it is using
network which is that much more
expensive for those of you who have
already been using UCP or pretty much
any other club rather you know that not
all networking costs the same some of it
costs nothing this specific thing cost a
lot
so naturally we wanted to optimize it
and if we go further down the line you
can also see that throughout roughly the
last five or six months we've actually
focused our development efforts on
bringing this network cost down and you
can see how this nice little line keeps
dropping and dropping and dropping and
this kept making our CFO happier and
happier which is a lot of my job now
somewhere all the disappointing time
you're probably gonna try and squint and
figure out whether all these lines
really mean what I say they meant and
surprisingly enough we had the exact
same problem it's called cognitive load
when you look at a graph with like 50
lines trying to explain what your
networking cost is another 80 trying to
explain what your CPU cost you're like
you're gonna have a hard time and graphs
should be easily read at this point
we're gonna jump back to our marvelous
little view and we're going to augment
it with case clause specifically this
now what we were doing here actually is
we were taking the different SKUs and
trying to group them into slightly more
coherent groups what you'll see here is
various commitments preemptable cores
RAM and all sorts of networking stuff we
chose to do this and not join it with a
lookup table mostly because we have zero
control over the actual SKUs going into
the system because they're controlled by
Google and throughout the last couple of
years they have changed if it wants in a
while
and what was more important to us was to
have these groups as stable as possible
and now if we go back here and we look
at the graph by this nifty little skew
then you can see that indeed I was not
lying my teeth and that the main costs
insanely so is this purple little line
that kept going down and down and down
again making a lot of people happy at
this point in time you're probably gonna
try and ask me what happened October and
sneak preview we did not get a bunch of
coupons that we entered in the system
dropping our costs about two weeks
before this point in time we got a lot
of people starting to complain about how
they were losing the bigger picture and
they're quite right you know we went
from very coerce kind of SKU and product
based information all the way down to
the specific building component with
nothing in between so at that point in
time naturally we started adding more
and more labels onto our resources to
get more information
unfortunately we kind of missed this
little piece of the documentation which
basically says that once you cross the
1,000 unique label value line it starts
discarding them so the end result was
complete loss of visibility because it
kept the labels that we weren't actually
interested in and then obviously we
fixed it but being aggressive people we
wanted to both have what we wanted and
still have the whole thing work so we
went back to our view again have I
mentioned how much I liked this view and
here we decided here we decided to join
that building component that we had with
a slightly smaller data set which is
just going to be those enrichments that
we added before since they were
relatively kind of static for those of
you in the data warehouse business this
is kind of like a star schema but not
really so here we added stuff like which
product is
company was surveying which serviced a
few general details whether it was
production or non production but it was
manually scalar auto scale and a bunch
of other stuff that I'm not going to
mention here because I don't want to
dive too deep into it and then if we
again go back we can see that we can now
bunch stuff up into those let's call
them
uber services and the difference here in
terms of what you can do with your
development efforts is that if you
usually looked at just like a single
component then you're gonna be doing
some local optimizations here you can
look at a much broader spectrum and for
example this imagine that this kind of
said for your life front end or API or
something of the like
and here you can start thinking about
slightly more cross-cutting changes like
using a different protocol or looking at
a different processing mechanism now at
this point in time this was like I don't
know two months ago three months ago we
were ecstatic everything was great we're
really happy and then this came needless
to say a 13% increase in costs is not a
good thing for anyone and really really
makes most people angry especially when
you're keep telling them that everything
is improving I am or is it and the
problematic part is that life doesn't
exist in a vacuum
especially your costs and at that point
in time we were growing at an insane
rate and you know we didn't want to be
the guys who kind of raised the wrong
flag so we wanted to kind of improve how
we were looking at things and try to
take out that noise within the signal
that we were looking at and the way that
we chose to do this is start looking at
relative figures instead of the
absolutes if you remember up till now we
looked at dollars and what we decided to
look at was the relative cost of pushing
a million
Paige user requests through our system
and by that kind of try and take out the
traffic fluctuations the way that we did
that back to our marvelous view was once
again joined billing data with some more
business metrics that were already there
because you know we run a business and
we need to know how much traffic is
coming through and once we took this
information and moved back to data
Studios you can see or like what all of
you can do as well you can add something
called a calculated field in this case
something quite simple in case you're
not being able to this is like the final
cost divided by the amount of traffic
and then when you look at it things
start to make slightly more sense over
here you can see that as I mentioned
before everything is fine cost is indeed
going up but our cost efficiencies are
going down again this makes most of the
people happy on our end just as an
example if we take another look at the
services we looked at before this is the
same cost efficiency metric for that
service and you can see that indeed it
has went down with this day being a
party that we full one when we went down
that low kind of try and summarize our
experiences from the last couple of
years I think what I want to leave you
with is three things the first of which
is label everything and when I say
everything I mean like everything at
least once probably not more than once
because that would be bad but even if
you don't see the value in it now
you're really gonna want to label it
because further down the line when stuff
does grow you're going to lose that
history and that never comes back the
second is that human beings are
inherently good and when you show them
this information
you're probably going to be surprised
with the amount of negative emotions
that they're gonna throw at you what we
found is that this is mostly because
it's some muscle most people do not flex
that often I don't know a lot of
societies that teach their children how
to manage budgets well or deal with
money and the more that you connect the
money end of things to what they're
actually building and what they are good
at and and practice a lot for example
the building components or the actual
traffic and the business metrics then
the more they're gonna be willing to
take this as something that they're in
charge of and the third sequel's your
friend a billing invoice for us right
now is somewhere between six and seven
million lines in the building export
there's no way that you're gonna be able
to make understand what's going on there
without reporting in aggregations and
that's what sequel is for and with that
I'd like back
Jannik and can we switch back to the
slides I'm so glad you're absolutely
right making your CFO happy is critical
I'm sure everyone has to kind of figure
that out themselves
besides you or three takeaways I also
want to add in my three T or four
takeaways actually four best practices
for everyone who has graciously attended
this session first being on day one not
day 30 day 90 on day 1 start exporting
your billing billing data into bigquery
so you can start billing costs analysis
dashboards so you can actually have that
data in the first place so that when
potentially problems arise when you
spend increases beyond what you're
expecting you have that data so you can
actually go back in do some some
analysis you know exactly where that
data is you already have your dashboards
all that stuff instead of in the heat of
the moment trying to collect the data
figure where figure out where all of it
is and then run through all these sequel
queries and stuff like that so start
capturing it on day one second thing is
structure and organize your projects or
organizations your folders your labels
all that stuff across all of your
different GCP resources so
aloud you're 100% right by just throwing
everything into one single project or
not using labels doesn't really give you
any kind of fine-grained control over
what you're spending on and how those
spins are affecting your business etc so
make sure that you start actually using
resource hierarchies labeling labeling
assets putting items into into projects
into folders all that stuff
third is make sure that you're
configuring the right kind of policies
for the right kind of people who have
access to control cost to set budgets to
set alerts all that kind of stuff so
rather than just giving free rein to
everyone to start spending as much as
they want maybe you have like department
heads or something like that or or you
use things like Google Groups where the
production team has more control over
spending habits than the dev test team
something like that so that spend
doesn't go out of control and you start
trying to scramble and find out what
happened when and fourth is building a
culture of show back in your org I've
talked to a bunch of different customers
about this some customers call it shame
back I'll kind of let you guys decide on
which culture fit is right for your
company but essentially the ability to
regularly review these billing reports
and custom dashboards with your team's
with your business units etc and then
regularly setting up budgets and alerts
so that you can closely monitor your
costs and you can alert stakeholders
when costs start to increase things
start to become concerning what have you
so that you can catch the train way
before it leaves the station
[Music]